[Music]
there were warnings before this day of
rallies that president jaya bolsonaro
was undermining brazilian democracy
he's trailing the former president luis
inacio lula de silva in opinion polls
for next year's elections which he says
he's not prepared to lose
we don't want disruption we don't want
to fight with any branch but we can't
accept anybody's efforts to distort our
democracy we can't accept anybody who
puts our freedom at risk
he's referring to the supreme court
which is investigating him and members
of his family on corruption charges his
handling of the pandemic has also cost
him support almost 600 brazilian deaths
have been recorded
but i do fear the impact of the actions
of bolsonaro towards the quality of
brazilian democracy because we have seen
in the last years bolsonaro undermining
the strength of many democratic
institutions
such as the national congress the
judicial power
his attacks on the free press and so on
president bolsonaro however still enjoys
substantial support and he called on his
loyal followers to show it
a president elected with 57 million
votes can't be accused of organizing a
coup that's a lie because he won the
presidency in the first round
what we want is freedom of expression to
be able to work
we want a free brazil in which the
people are heard bolsonaro lets us speak
many of his opponents stayed at home
saying they wanted to prevent clashes
but they believe the tide is turning
against the president who divides brazil
it's not just political groups here but
a protest of people who are here to
defend democracy the other protest is by
those defending a coup attempt
bolton has a strategy of destruction he
is violent a terrorist since he was
young and unfortunately he's now arming
the population
tight security kept the rival rallies
apart and there were few violent
incidents reported however they clearly
showed that brazil is as polarized now
as it has been for many years and both
sides are preparing for what threatens
to be a long and bitter election
campaign
daniel schweinler al jazeera